I've done something, I've done something I shouldn't have done, okay, oh shit, I should
have shot them, sorry, I'm going to be in a game, I'm going to hit the frat one thing
and I've just gone off of it, like a dumb boom
okay, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it
good morning, good evening, good afternoon, my name is Dronecuddles and I'm here to try and
entertain you to the best of my ability, all things considered, um, I may or may not have
only had four hours of sleep because I have issues sleeping at the moment, okay, there's a bit
of a swap today, um, I do not have an intention today of streaming 12 hours, oh what, it's not
sustainable if you can't get sleep, oh well, now that I've learned that, yeah, actually you're kind
of right, reeflings, oh no, uh, you actually need to unironically, apartment a bed, um,
I did not get much sleep, so I have decided instead of doing endurance, kind of, you know, fly
through the DLC, I would very much like to get the coconuts with you, so I've able to source
where the, um, the coconuts, which is, hello, please help, thank you, wonderful, apologies,
you're beautiful, let's go, and my beloved, I cannot source the location of the DLC Pratt,
they're called Prattles, I believe, no, they're called a Prattling Patez, but we all know it's a
coconut, let's be honest, why no sleep, uh, look on what's been uploaded, that's why no sleep,
I started working on another audio, and I've an announcement, Patreon is getting fed the
moment I go offline, uh, my plot is pit, job, my armpit, the plot is my armpit, okay, and then
we're writing the fourth plot live so you guys can literally see how, like, the script, and then
you'll hear the finished edit, like, result type thing, but, uh, yeah, for some reason, I picked
armpit, I can't even remember what you even said in the script, but, um, you got to sleep and drop
the bread for, I'm still a biohazard at the moment as well, um, all I produced was a singular little,
you know, one could argue it was the size of a gold nugget, um, but I would very much like to do
the crack, crack, the prattling coconut, sorry, my brain isn't here, I'm, I do apologize, let's
have four hours, I was like, I'm doing stuff, I'm currently waiting on a fucking contract, um,
from a bloody company, so I've got the girl's good news, and they're just, they're fucking
being at all their sweet time, like, they're in no rush to seal the deal, whereas I'm like, this is
an, wait, what, my mouse and my, oh, okay, my, uh, like, this is a big deal for the girls,
because it's yet another revenue income, so, blah, blah, blah, I know, boring, boring, boring,
business, business, business, that's what it's like behind the scenes, it's all boring, boring,
boring, business, business, business, okay, located in Stormfoot Catacombs, which is in the cliff
side, northwest of the church of Ella, why is my cursor, is the church down here, yeah, okay,
the first coconut is to the left, of course you guys are more than welcome to stream snap, let's
be honest, oh, maybe I should change the name of the stream, people are gonna be like, oh, I'm
leveling up the L3, so I can play with her, okay, hold on, let me get my pizza, but yes, it's gonna
be a two hour stream, I have a collab tomorrow as well with Yumi Plus, and hold on, I'm gonna do a
coconut little, little coconut gathering, and I'm gonna like do it in green, because we are harvesting,
like real farmers, I'm literally just gonna be doing nice and easy today, two hours, I'm redirected
into Shibi, she's doing a drawing stream, because Shibi has some doodling art, I'm pretty sure,
just show me her art, am I going first? No, I don't think she showed me her art in an interview,
but she does, she's able to do stuff, can we have the three reflands on a beach with coconut trees,
okay, the first, hello, prattling, no, we're gonna try and do that, if we've got enough time,
obviously, I think we may or may not blast through these catacombs, but as long as we've all got the
same coconut, that's amazing, I had something to tell you that was exciting, out of the ASMR
collab, and I've already forgotten, hello, yes, that's the one we're going for, okay, we need to
locate it at Stormford Catacombs, which is the closest just north west of the church, we are
going to take that very literally, and just jump over here and look for a cavern this way, I can't
jump, okay, sorry, okay, hold on, I need to go around, sorry, that's embarrassing, I can't make that
jump, I'm too weak, I'm too weak, right, north west, oh, we have our head and we've got a beacon,
the ASMR collab was really good, I loved it, it's not putting much, it's so early, it's too strong,
bro, it's literally my favorite, oh, are these guys that tell you where the Prattland coconut's at?
Can we get down here safely? I'm not sure about, wait, that was a bird, I thought it was a reefland
that just launched themselves, I'm like, ain't not a bit early to be launching ourselves off a
cliff first thing in the morning, and I believe AC had concluded an ASMR stream today, I love how
you guys literally like the beacons that go on door, I'm just following, I'm like okay, I'm here
for war, what's going on? I have good news and bad news, bad news, Emmy's away on holiday, good news
is I can edit Emmy and AC's collab together, because I've got all the pieces of the Puzzlemer,
wow, okay, we're here, we're here, oh no, I'm gonna have to resummon you all,
wait, that doesn't count, wait, okay, maybe I need to be a big girl and travel on my own,
and then summon inside the cavern, literally clapping like yeah, we have to go already,
you literally just got in, Emmy gone for two, now there is content for Emmy, I've got plans
that there's gonna be like something every three days, at least whether that's a short,
look how dark inside it gets when my refunds leave, I hear it here, okay, so there's a
prattling coconut in here, just summon a singular gate, oh is there a hit 5k, that's fantastic,
I think AC's literally about to do it around the corner, oh no, this can't be, wait, can I not hire
you guys, hire, I really hope this next game has seamless co-op, if only, that's asking for too
much, hold on a minute, that's asking for a bit too much, you mean you want help to play your
FromSoft game, hmm, no, unlikely, you're not allowed to, you will be given 20% less damage,
boss gets 20% more, and you're freaking healing flasks to nothing,
when do we expect the collab, so some, if you want to know the behind the scenes,
oh fuck, that's what I need you guys for, holy shit, how could I forget,
reeflings, all we need holders rise up, there's been a bit of an update
that may or may not shape what happens with gen 2, but what happens in here stays in here,
did I make myself clear, you guys have done fantastic, I'm pretty sure no one's done anything major,
I need, I need influence, I need interest and I need descriptions, I need attributes of some
milf body type and a lollipop body type, I need some sort of influence, there's been a bit of
development, and two designs have been rejected in both categories, and I'm needing to start somewhere
fresh, now I did think harpy, harpy with a knee hands and wings instead, which is a bit advanced
for a modler to be honest, she'd probably end up being the most expensive to rejuice,
I snapped her attention at reeflings, dragon, oh that's right, sorry, dragon and then the color scheme
was based after the big dragon and avatar, she's definitely like possessive,
and calls fan base her treasures possibly, that's a good one, I wrote that down, yeah remember
that, okay, we're also consider a harpy, maybe she's egg obsessed, I'm actually kind of down with
an egg obsessed lollipop harpy, maybe she would call her fan base like, oh what would you, egg,
eggie, maybe call them, how about a female knight in armor, see the major thing about armor is the
pride, is can no one, can I not summon in here, sorry, can I not summon in here, hold on a minute,
I ain't laughing no more, no one's summonable, nestlings, hatchlings, yeah that kind of thing,
maybe we can kind of go the eggbound route, hatchling, right so we've got dragon and harpy
for a little bit more body type, so they don't have an interest in a lollipop cheerleader,
number one, bimbo lollipop cheerleader or bimbo milk cheerleader,
so bimbo cheerleader and then I'm going to put candy roll from kung fu keel,
did you activate the summoning, oh did I nullify it, oh I nullified it, sorry,
wait I heard that, oh no no no, okay there we go, right, oh no,
um alamia milk,
rushing under the gate, um alamia milk, come on, let me, we need pointed side ears,
I'm going to put that there and line me up for a mouth, because I like the pointed side ears and
I like the, you know the teeth and you know how it goes, like alamia milk, technical related,
I think the odds are I may or may not be getting some sort of technical alternative of the future,
if you want a bimbo cheerleader, um look at Nike,
and a harpy milk, actually you're fucking right, everyone goes harpy we won, but no one goes harpy
big yin, you're actually right, harpy milk, like and she would be clumsy, she'd be calling,
she'd be clumsy, harpy milk, hmm and then maybe her stick can be, she's always egg burning,
you need to help her lay eggs, like a freak, so then there's people on a birth, yeah you're
fucking welcome, I even consider you, you're welcome, okay let's see what the deal is,
whoa, okay we're going swinging,
yeah yeah yeah, I'm here to entertain all, don't say, don't say I don't feed you well over here,
when any other agency would reject you, they hated him, they hated her, because she spoke
the truth about the value of it, having true diversity, when it comes to an array of um,
alternative content, it's funny just because you're vanilla, or you shouldn't, wait,
did you not watch the membership stream, oh crap hold on,
okay thank god I'm one shotting,
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh, wow why is there so much fire,
oh yeah I'm back here,
oh we already did it, oh okay that one went by very quickly, right we'll finish the dungeon though,
we'll finish the dungeon though, um okay that was a lot quicker than I thought, obviously because
we're like mega overpowered here, and the reflins are doing it all for us, oh there's one more,
uh strone, it's because if only you knew, oh no, oh no this can't be,
uh right is anyone got any milf suggestions that I can work on,
uh I think I'm gonna see if I can get that dragon,
out of all, I'm feeling the dragon the most on the missing section,
what you're completely leaking any development plans, nope that's not how it works, it's not how
it works, I am literally all six girls at the agency, why do you think my voice is sore, I just
did ASMR not even 30 minutes ago, hello I'm Icy Snowpies, um today I did ASMR, I'm so sorry Icy I
cannot do your life justice, your life your voice justice, sorry I got a little life steal there,
oh I'm wondering actually, what's wrong guys, actually I was wanting to ask you,
if I ever got a lollipop version of a motto, am I allowed to maintain the gap mo with this voice,
or would you guys want me to proper like fucking have a go at the voice, if I ever got it for the
funny ha ha, what's my job, do I get, do I keep keep my deep voice like my voice down here brother,
and coming at a wee tiny thing, or I'll go over ready, a fairy girl with a bahunka, funny you mentioned
that, okay I do not know, oh it's the cat, oh it's the cat that has like really weird fucking
str- oh I hate that, oh my god I hate that, sorry I just got like so much height, sorry I know we
absolutely obliterated it, but oh my god that was scary, I did not like that, thank you, okay we can
now mark off the prattling hello, I'm gonna put, can you guys, no no yeah no that one yeah I don't
know where it is, right I'm gonna put an x next to it because we collected it, fantastic, everybody
a sorceress, no I am so sorry witches are fucking everywhere right now, they are absolute, you blink
in an agency's like witch by the way, it's not a fucking design that I can mark, oh sorry
that was, that was a quiet part, said out loud in frustration, okay please help, located in the
impaler's hathacones, which is northeast, northeast shore of the weeping peninsula,
what, of the weeping peninsula, oh merda, weeping peninsula, we think, we think,
I don't have a weeping peninsula, that sounds like a really good euphemism, you want to see my
weeping peninsula, they're just here to catch me, I swear to god we're in the space, go to
castle mourn rampart, are you, you're stormy veil castle, so where's the other castle
do you have a dolusy v to bring out the amount of toggles, not, not sorceress,
soccer, fitball, you want me to put a fitball v to burden, no, I actually thought about getting a
a plant girl that uses pheromones, oh I like pheromone milk, hold on,
that's not going to happen in general, plant pheromone milk,
right sorry, I can't understand English, oh god bro, okay sorry, hello, I'm the next location we
need to go to is the impaler's catechons and I've already forgotten what my instructions were,
where on earth south of the map castle mourn rampart, south of the map castle mourn rampart,
can you understand me now, oh okay that's good, I'm glad you can understand me now, I'm just
going to maintain this voice so I am easily accessible to everyone who listens, yeah, a bit of a,
a bit of a ditzy English wife moment, don't you want to wife me, I'm so English, I love the way
the British empire crumbled, even though it put sentry, why the fuck did you crumble it, you had
everything, yeah I had everything gone for you, but anyway that's just me, I know, I know, you guys
can't be spun in, oh no, what is she saying, what do you think of my dark elf, oh man,
melfer pop, if you see a suggestion say melfer pop so I can visualize it in my head
with my little thumb print, I regret what I have done exactly, don't ever, don't ever
ask for a different accent again, I'm just kidding, you're not in trouble, but if you were you'd be
bent over my knee right now, pop, pop, pop, is there only one good refling, only one good
refling to chit chat to chit chat to, wow, I'm sorry, a little mushroom, lollipop, funny you
mentioned that, that's really, uh right I'm just, I'm just envisioning in my head
what, with your suggestions, I think right bimbo tier leader is out, although that's kind of that,
the window to opi loli, oh pe, well who the fuck, oh pe, pe ie, lollipop,
Celtic warrior, I have terrible news, I'm the Celtic warrior, I'd be the one that fit that the best,
oh shit you just taken one, oh wow you walloping his ass, I'm helping, I'm helping
oh shit he's still alive, oopsies, I thought once he's knocked off that, let me let me drink
the milf anglerfish, well I was just thinking if we did a milf lamia and obviously they would
have to be, oh I just spawned them in game, I just spawned them in, get me my reflings back,
right now I'm too scared for one more, even though I'm like super level, like I'm, I think I'm
exponentially leveled up right now, a southern bell milf, I see that, the problem with those
kind of things is you'd need someone to fill the role and I have to admit we were playing it very
risky having a zeroes design created, because someone has to fill a role and if you're looking for
like a southern sweetheart actor, oh it's my cherry pie, oh my cherry pie, like and then you
then you get a cherry pie that applies, it's like oh you're up shit for me, dark elf milf, I'd even
fill the role for you, have I, I'd actually, I think this, dark elf milf, what's her angle,
will you need me to give me more, what's the dark elf angle other, other than she looks fucking,
I want to rub oil all over her and lick it off manually,
okay do you know where to go, I actually don't know where to go, sorry let me check it out,
located in the impaler's catacomb, right, impaler's catacomb, okay I've definitely not
discovered what the heck it is then, do you know where to take me, do you have impaler's catacomb on
your side, a self, what about a lollipop dragon, I am going to submit, no I just got you here,
why is everything fucking hiding from me, I'm so sorry every fling, right okay I'll stop calling
everyone in until I actually get to location, because I keep messing up, thank you, I keep
messing up, excuse me, what did he say, okay I hope that's like a, how do you call it, right
there's something up here, something up here, okay I'm super overleveled, I'm super overleveled,
I don't need to be scared, I am super overleveled, I do not need to be scared,
the reeflings are gonna help me and then I'll be prepared, oh Mr. Reefling, hold my hand,
bum bum bum bum, I hope you don't mind my sweaty fucking hands, bum bum bum bum, they don't stop
sweating, it's kinda embarrassing, you can actually get both hooks in your hands if it's a bed,
bum bum bum bum, if you did an angler fish, literally hook, line and sinker on our forehead
would be quite a funny moat, have I got you yet, hook, line and sinker,
that's what the moat or the angler fish would be, where the fuck am I going,
wait I think I've actually downly discovered it, hold on wait guys I'm getting on my memory,
I'm getting on my memory, have I been here before, well I've not been here in this game,
surely my rawtism your honor, oh my god I'm actually so smart, I'm actually so smart,
I've been a whole freaking year, get me in here, okay if you technically make a, if you technically
make a velar girl you can link your stories because also a hard piece thing to make fishermen think,
no I do not like, I fucking, do not, hold on let me finish this,
um I, wait why would it be nullified, there's someone here, well Jen too,
have someone who's good at singing, actually some of the girls are looking to develop,
they're, they're singing, geez reefland, um I, I'm not going to specifically hire someone just
because they can sing because at the end of the day you gotta be a drummer and you gotta be able
to give us the notes while you, oh you know when you have your little firework at the end of the day
um that's where we need the, the pipes to come in, that's when we need the pipes to come in so
you know just because you can sing it doesn't mean you're getting in, you know what I'm saying, like
yeah, yeah I mean it's cool and all but like, now the, now what would be interesting is if you
know how to do parody songs and shit, that is different, it's, wow, oh I missed, I missed that
so embarrassed, okay we're super leveled up, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, we're super leveled up,
um yes if someone applied then they're like hey I do like parodies, I know how to write them, I
know how to edit them, then that is a very big asset um because not only could I help promote
them like their own content, like I can put like money into their parodies, I can put money into
like whatever they do type thing so it's really good like a different advertising type thing for
them whereas like if you're like yeah I can sing but I actually don't know how to like
make parodies in it or that kind of thing, that's like oh well you can do song covers,
don't get me wrong, that's good and all but it's quite valuable being able to kind of
have more of a skill set beyond I can sing, is that, I don't, oh no are we in trouble,
we're playing, we're playing, I wasn't prepared, what do we do, we play wait we go underneath
what, oh what are you doing, we go whoa whoa wait whoa what do we do, oh no
is this the troll room, are we being trolled right now, down, down, down we go down me, oh no, okay hold on
oh everything you're suspecting, no farmer's slave girl, are you joking me, I can't tell if
you're trolling or not, what you want someone that is like a fucking, what, what part are you
supposed to, to exactly, oh we got him, we got him, we got him, we got the coconut, uh but
coconut, uh but coconut, okay we already got the second one, oh my god there's so many items here
to scavenge, are you a fake wolf, no you're real,
mommy's dying, no there's a lot more going in place, I'm, I think, uh
there's a lot more coming up, um I'm gonna get feedback from the girls very soon TM if they
think they'd benefit from like a manager type thing, obviously, oh my god people and there's
so many, just climb, just climb, just climb, there's so many, they keep coming, um a pirate, no we're
not doing pirate, I'm so out of it, fucking, Mercy got memed on at one point for being a pirate, I'm
like oh my god, I think she's got both of her eyes relaxed, it's what she could be in the dark
right
yes I'm gonna see if the girls think they'll benefit from a manager, but the thing is because we're
so hands off, it's like well what do you need to manage, you get to dictate all your games,
you get to dictate all your streams, you get to dictate absolutely everything you do, the only,
and hell you can even write scripts if you want, if you hate the scripts you're being provided with,
like it's kind of that scenario where it's like a manager normally will like tell you what to do
and it's kind of like well we've actually done the opposite of that on purpose, why is there baby
gargoyles as well, that's cheating, oh that's so creepy, please don't do that again, you understand
me, oh okay that's fine, it's fine, I'm a brave, I'm a brave soldier, mummy's bravest warrior,
mummy's bravest warrior, okay okay we're good, we're good, okay thank you for your service,
okay we've already got the second one, let's go, an ex Nazgul rider, okay now you've got my
attention, now you speak in lord of the rings, no I'm not fucking getting she love commissioned,
we can't do insects, I'm happy to tell you the insider and all the things but if you
fucking become an insect like I'm sorry but you're just, you're kind of nerfing yourself because
people genuinely have like insane arachnophobia and stuff and again like if you're a VTuber that
only has one eye, like a mono eye or like like 18 billion eyes on your model, again people don't
like that, I saw how brains work, right thank you, uh tomb ward catacomb, located in catacomb in the
cliff south of the church of Pilgrimage in the Weepin Peninsula, did I? Church of Marica, church
of Pilgrimage, located in which is the south, east, south east, Dullhands, no no Dullhands either,
a gimmick lasts about five seconds and then that's like a jeek and literally never streamed,
um more fish themed girl, leave math fishy to see out of this, right sorry what was in the
uh in the cliff south of the church in south of the church
bug lovers are like 0.1% yeah it's like I don't want to give someone something I think would
actually severely nerf them or doesn't have like the cliff south of the church
I see a cliff
what this just looks like new oh wait there's a statue there I can touch hold on
an extremely controlling AI moment um actually I'll let you on the inside your knowledge
having AI or anything close to it design wise where you'd actually tag it as AI
eh your content gets nerfed into the ground so don't we're there heck are you going behind that tree
is it just dead ahead
hi ho silver oh it's right it literally was hidden perfect this is it I'm sorry
what about spirit sword like fear for zelba just call her a robot maybe you can
create and come up with a unique fantasy creature oh god no it's so it's one thing to commission
inspiration is a whole other kind of fish to commission something that has not even been
concepted before that is when you're like you are asking for like hell on earth development
um absolute heck on earth development
sorry I'm just looking at the notes you guys are giving me a roman matron very elegant
we go need to find taste but we need to channel the gimmick is we're abusing our power and stuff
what do you mention abusing power you found power
mm-hmm
the heck is behind this and there's death
is there an enemy oh the skeletons I was looking for the wee guys
I'm like oh is it one of those ones oh my god they're so big
hey an alchemist no any witchy type stuff sorry there's so many agencies have come out
with witches recently I've had enough I didn't want to see another one I've had to pack it in
pack it in I don't want to see am I doing this alone oh my god am I gonna be brave for once
oh I'm gonna have to I'm not I don't feel that brave anymore I don't feel that brave anymore
oh no this isn't the repeating dungeon one is it oh lord
oh no this cannot be okay I can't actually kind of regret going on my own right now
why are you so fast okay well the skeleton problem's been dealt with accordingly
oh he gets up as well stop it go back down I'm scared
uh kiss me
it's a bit generic but I wouldn't
ow it goes both ways I thought I only went one way stop it
burning me
you swear fully wait bonk and then jump on it
and up
was that not just here
oh offend the levels
I'm so brave only because I'm literally level 200 in like what a level 14 area
I'm such a brave girl I'm such a brave girl honestly
am I going the wrong way
why are they so fast they have like insane agility
fuck you I'm doing the boss by your moan
how does a mantik world what's a mana core a fucking unicorn and a praying mantis together
oh what the hell all right thank god I do yeah I was gonna say holy crap that was a creepy design
I don't like him wait there's supposed to be a coconut in here I'm an idiot
wait a minute I'm supposed to get a coconut I'm gonna wait hold on a minute please
I am the fuck is the coconut
you mean my coconut yabams
where is it that's where I just came from oh it's only where you can go
uh coconut up but coconut
I don't see anything a scavenge hold on and you find an item hold on you just hold on so you
just stay there wait I went up instead of around maybe I was supposed to do that he means
right fuck it wow whoa I like rolled into that and go whoa kablamo'd buy it wow
oh you know for a skill
but he's he's scratching his b-bone head
he's thinking he's not the thinker would a mana core be too complex I don't even
have a theory and we tried it may or may not go rejected
is the coconut down here stop it oh where did you come from okay now you're like a phantom
stop it
coconut are you a coconut
I'm so brave I did it all myself as well what do you mean I'm level 200 and I didn't do it myself
no I I did it myself don't be silly this is all me
uh Strony it doesn't actually count as clear in an area if you're over like 200 levels of the
recommended level look look give me a fucking break right give me a break man I just want some
prattling coconuts is that too much to ask
oh my god I've got aim but I can just sense when it's time to go I'm like get me out of here right
we did it yeah okay would you like oh how about I retired ain't that just then
we can't for anyone who is lurking and you're like why does the agency not bring on IPs
I would never actually want someone to sell me the IP because that is yours it should belong to you
and I don't think and I know some people like well you can just do basic adoption IP you have to
hand over so many rights because in theory if you come aboard but you still own your IP I then
have to ask you to get promotional art of you like to do promotional things with your character
does they make sense can he make sense in like the way the business is set up so honestly just
have fun you've got a fun new character enjoy it for what it's worth and yes I'm happy to make
adjustments or 2.0 you know all that just um we are your friends you will never be alone again
wonderful the clated low places in the cliff bottom catacombs which is on the southeastern shore
of lulu lake are you linari lake what are you located in the cliff bottom catacomb
which is on the southeastern shore
sure
I can't see on the map a capybara what we give her whiskers a subbie lollipop
I mean what do you think aces for uh can I don't gave me
uh I'm at linario lake shore I don't I actually don't know
uh what the deal is
oh
not everyone can tell how good my ways are
you've a discerning eye you are sometimes yummy yummy yummy yummy yummy why not if it's
literally not even is there any leaflings that can spawn them oh hey leafling there's two leaflings
I think I might have killed all the other leaflings with my stamina eat eat
if ac is subbie I'm an apple pie what does that mean what does that mean what does that translate
what do you mean by that so only thinks ac is subbie um how do I tell you
how do I tell you
yeah they're both brats right and what do what do we do with brats we correct them
do we not
you need to tame the wild beast with ac that's the that's the angle are you seeing you want
someone who isn't a challenge stop stop wimpering oh wait I can talk to you now
hello thank you for joining thank you for all joining my new three night game
I know they're both wimpering they're rubbing it in my face right okay we follow the gating
light to the next coconut which is the wonderful ac is a princess you cherish more than a brat you
correct yeah that's what I'm saying like ac is brave
um
would I say emmy was concepted to be
her mother
I would see
I would actually say they're actually both of them concepted to be
subbed with a few barriers in the way how about we say that so
and emmy doesn't necessarily like anyone outside of her big brother and she's very subdued
um when she gets access to you um I don't I don't know if I said this you know her banner on
twitter the one where she's hugging the hoodie so that's your hoodie and her book is open she
basically just communed with you and um whilst you're hoodie um because she still has the ability
to talk to you even though you're dead through the book and through like her her powers that she's
gaining over time like she's a she's you're still able to talk to one another like
I don't know I'm only seeing six I mean if you
that's how you feel she she and if that's how you feel I'm gonna argue thank you for getting me
and her 2.0 it has her wear in the big brochure yes if you didn't know the hoodie that emmy wears
and her fresh jays are actually your clothes because she wants to be closer to you at all times
and um she had to stitch back whoa who's farting a storm up in here um she after your little incident
with that went terribly wrong she stitched back your hoodie um okay both of us missed that was
rather embarrassing um and that's why her hoodie has little stitch marks and stuff all over it
and then those are your fresh jeans um yeah a dummy orc lady
so I do like that I don't know if giving a green skin to someone is the wisest of ideas
okay where are we going did they go the wrong way
you that was an honest mistake oh no we're here we're here you did it we fling you did it you
gated me okay inside is the wonderful coconut no don't whimper because you have to go it's fine
wait how are you whimpering while you do that move away him dummy blue troll a muscle girl
uh I did have her concept but her design got rejected by me I'm happy to talk about it um
if the concept artist is happy I'm waiting on the other concept artist to give me a few things
at the moment um but she's been a bit radio silent um and I'm not really sure what
right I'll see if any of you guys can spawn in but I don't know like because I'm like
insanely over leveled or something the game's just like uh yeah you don't need anyone in
I'll see if anyone pops up maybe I'll just hire Shrek stop that's what I'm saying like I don't I
wouldn't want to give someone a green skin like I think someone's like oh by a lollipop fucking
goblino and I'm like you're I want to give models that will give people success I don't want to
hand over models where I'm like oh my god I actually don't think you have a good angle here you know
when you say a design is rejected what does that mean it means I've given a prompt to the concept
artist the concept artist has given me something either I want to develop further but then as the
renditions kept happening nothing was it didn't go the way it just wasn't working out so um that's
a rejection when I when I say like okay do not develop any further this isn't working out that's
a rejection I've also done a straight up rejection where um a concept has been given um and I didn't
I was I wasn't interested in developing it at all because it just was not doing anything now this is
where the two concept artists come together because one is male one is female and I actually think
that's a really important development factor because oh male guys female guys blah blah blah
but it's important to see how two people can take the same concept and end up with something different
an ax a little girl I'm pretty sure there's an ax a little girl in another agency oh I heard that
isn't it how only one oh sorry I just said then people do love goblin girls I know but
I'm going to be honest if I signed up for an agency and they handed me a fucking green little
goblin girl I have and then I got to see my other gen mates designs I have to admit I think I'd be
pretty salty the Loch Ness monster you'd need a you'd need a scott wait finally they come through
oh for goodness sorry I keep sitting down sorry sorry wait can I get you can I get you an eight
about um
yeah Lottie yeah sorry someone's already claimed the ax a little angle I have to admit
oh yeah no her name's Lottie and stuff I think she's just left her agency
goddess of destruction is there is kind of a part I'm not really wanting to feel opposite
I don't want to give a design where it's like all these girls are intertwined because of
some hams you know some hams and I don't want like the girls to be intertwined like lower-wise
or anything like that okay we're gonna get wonderful I believe this one how are you invisible
why are you okay I went up oh they're suckling each other wait wait wait that's my job that's my job
hey that's my job what are you doing that's what I'm supposed to do a tomboy engineer
I oh wait wait what's the enemy there um
funny mention that I was interested in someone with goggles on their head but Bonnie just came out
recently from globey question mark I'm so sorry it's very hard to keep up with all the names and
agencies and faces but there is someone who came out recently that has goggles on their head um
I'm a mechanic although it'd be really funny for her to do that meme like what's gender are you
I'm a mechanic wait isn't this the false path one are you sure this isn't the false path one
replay okay they're sure I'm sorry I'm done I'm sorry we flings for doubting you
uh right oh oh sorry oh sorry sorry big man that was me oh you're right there we man
oh my god the arrow that's literally in my butt right now ow I'm literally shrek right now
ow what are you doing oh
huh oh
that was rather frightening that was rather frightening
wait oh he's getting tea bagged over here you've ever been jealous of an arrow before
I think her name is Bonnie I it's Bonnie because I remember being like oh Bonnie last Scotland
but I didn't get in oh wait is this the one that has that secret fucking thing under here is it this one
oh am I just making it up in one of these catacombs have like a fake wall somewhere
oh is it oh look at I'm hanging upside down
literally anti-gravity magic well he got his arse locked oh my god is this where my prattling
coconut is no it's a mirror helm uh do you think our connections are complimenting each other
no I think our connections are not complimenting each other at all
she's just coming after her fans to end their existence wait what being an immortal snail
ah funny mention that I kind of was like oh that would be kind of cute but um
um considering people thought I was a snail because of my shells in my hair I was a bit like
in general we should use the fearless uh considering every character came out with their favorite
what to make gen 2 no
you know you cannot do that oh are you okay refling or sneakling actually
did the lag just kill you
what did you oh did the lag just kill you oh shit sorry I think I hit the plate
okay I got it wait no I didn't that's a sight oh where the heck is this
hattlin hattlin
so be the way not this way apparently
gen 2 just do yourself a genuine but evil and I'll start doing weird voices I think that's a
that's a a fool's day prank or something like that
where the heck are we going oh sorry sorry I did it again I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
well I'm too busy yapping okay I'm too busy yapping maybe a gargoyle girl
yeah but then how do you how do you stick it in that's where we just were
I think this is the one that has like a hidden wall or something
I don't know what wall it is though
במס
snack
it's the one with the light no is it you
is it you is it you
know is it you know is it you you know is it you know
no is it you no okay it's all there do you know what to do
we're just
wait this is it no no no fucking warrior loses it and starts smacking walls
and cover it in a cat comb okay okay oh you've got torch you know where go sorry
and only girl
oh yeah I mean it's alright out again I'm so sorry I hope you have a heel I'm
sorry oh down let's go
oh yeah
like a great team is this my praline coconut no it's not my praline
coconut is there another thing are you my I got it I got it I got it even though
I'm taking a hammer and I still got it yeah okay where's the box I wish I was
yeah you know sit down sit down we're just woken up sit down first thing in
the mornin sorry one maybe a dive in our girl dive in our like the future
about you
even get developed I'm waiting on the female concept artist to be more things
and I'll see what happens but we're both inside
I'm gonna sword one of these things I think I'm just losing it I'm sure it
happened like freaking once in the game and I've never trusted it since like
everything must be able to open a dive in or isn't it a divine or a fortune
teller well I don't really I'm not really doing us you know it's not really
so if you do that you're gonna make me think I can't win okay what's the third
installment of this boss she oh shit I messed up rather embarrassing I'm like
level 200 I'm getting wallet I can't even get hit on them there oh no they have
high points I can't believe it I can't just spam jump attack oh it's terrible
oh okay we got Caden sale sword ashes how are you morning that's not what the
coconut in the reef and literally let's look at absolutely annihilated okay now
we mark off wonderful apologies your beautiful let's get to it in my
beloved apology apologies is located in the unsightly catacombs west of
perfumers grotto which is northwest of the abandoned coffin grace and sound
southeast Mount Gilmer you will come across you will come across this grace
after taking the covered path and killing the boss of room whatever you
could go down to no be amazing oh I hope so I think that's also probably why the
rejection rate is so high at the moment is cuz it's like it's just trying to get
everything right we're gonna go unsightly catacombs apparently up here
maybe oh abandoned coffin right we're going somewhere hold on I'm sure I
read abandoned coffin which is northwest of the abandoned coffin northwest of the
abandoned coffin I'm getting on this for a farmer girl nah cuz unique accent
northwest northwest okay one hour left literally I it's gonna be so weird
adjusting to only doing like two or streams four or streams when my dad
gets here cuz it's like what I do with all my time I mean at least I know like
I'm probably gonna go nuts like setting up collabs and stuff and getting loads of
edits done like I've uploaded an ASMR today my goal is to upload the 2k thank
you ASMR which is actually the 3k but hey we tried our best oh oh oh I think it
might just be down here I think it may just be down here okay okay we are good
to go we just need to shove a little key in the hole I'm good to shove them
things in holes I literally like doing a tour and forever stream is bizarre it's
like such a weird concept because like I finish and I'm like okay what now like
what the streamers do all their time what do you mean you're not streaming all
the time you still have to recover from your fruit injury I'm wondering if that's
why I can't see no cuz it's not that sorry anymore it's just it's just a bit
uncomfortable I have to admit my fur reeflings of milk just all dry your
manage well originally I thought my dad here was for just shy two weeks a tonial
girl okay okay you're done ready oh we are picking up apologies right now how
do I talk to you wonderful why does he sound sweet it literally sounds like he
said what day uh what the sigma what a black
honestly I like that hold on hold on let me read that one down
black Smith milk abs black milk muscle milk anything comes with it
oh wait a minute I think I lost my consciousness
whoa that didn't stagger wait am I going the wrong way sorry you guys don't
we'll just keep going I'm sure it'll be fine we can explore oh we've just done a
u-turn it's fine we didn't we didn't achieve anything we didn't have to go
oh is this a drop down kit no it's not a drop down do not drop down is this the
one with a hidden wall no is this the one with a hidden wall no I'm coming for
you whoa okay that did stagger no whoa they recover so fast from a staggers
I've lost my refling
refling hello I can hear them wait how did it did you guys fall down are they
down there wait is that dead I did so they did come down here
refling there you are but mummy's very slow in the head okay you have to give
me a second to close breathing
that then like here go if I read slime one more time yous are getting put it
is I get I'm not even time out yous are getting bent over the knee and spank no
Halloween outfit sure slime oh wait did someone actually time you out no you
don't actually time out slaves oh wait I see it how'd I get on it I cheese it I've
cheese didn't success somewhere are you the Prattling coconut are you the
Prattling cook I got it I got it I got the Prattling coconut coconut coconut
ooh are we ready adrenaline is pumping adrenaline is pumping
what we boldie ooh got Joe in here whoa whoa whoa whoa are you oh damn he got
some swipe on them okay but he got no boys ha ha no boys no win I love when
they have no boys it's my favorite thing I love when they have no boys it's my
favorite thing oh he's dying he told me to pose and then he bow and we flins are
so humble oh he give them a little clap they said yeah good effort me but not
happy happy happy happy happy happy happy happy happy happy chat will be gone by the same
string looks back wonka I like the idea of a dry yard to get a little especially
about bike special on the same time it's a dry art again other than me I try hard
listen I think I'm losing my mom right apolyd wait what did we just get we just
He's got apologies, let's hear it then, let's hear it then.
What about you?
What about, thank you!
Okay, and how about, oh no!
Oh, he's so smushed down!
Oh, amazing!
Feel very good.
And then Haya!
Oh, plant girl, yeah, sorry, plant girl, yeah.
I'm not bad.
So you need to spell stuff out for me, for where to click.
You're beautiful!
Located in the southwest side of the hermit village.
Hermit village, any hermit villagers?
Uh, it's hermit village.
Hold on, hold on.
Don't write me off yet.
So, hermit village.
Hermit village?
Hold on.
Uh, hermit village, northeast of the craft.
Man's shack?
Is this the wrong one?
Southeast of Volcano Manor.
Hermit village is in the swamp.
It's in Mill, Gilmore, west of the map.
Where I've not explored yet.
Like this?
Is it where I've not explored?
What about an angel lollipop?
Kind of defeats the purpose.
Defeats the purpose of wee bit.
Yeah, you didn't reach it yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's only one thing for it then, lads.
You guys are going to be walking me where we need to go.
What have I got so far?
I've got a lamia, but I'm going to have to be honest.
I think Dark Elf Milf has beaten her.
A milf, hard-faced, since it's always done the opposite.
But I don't know how that would play out.
I've got a blacksmith muscle milf.
I have a plant pheromone milf.
And for lollipop, I have a possessive dragon.
Then...
No, I had a harpy, but I think I'm getting that riddle.
And then I've got a cheerleader opi, but...
I can't really see it.
Sorry, my notes are down to the left here.
The tracking went off.
How did the fairy get rejected?
I can't really see it.
Why?
I think we just have to...
I'm happy to show the behind the scenes once everyone is out and shown and all of that.
And the girls can probably talk about it.
I look like this.
But I could have looked like this.
This is my original concept.
My prompt got completely changed.
AC's prompt got completely changed.
She was actually supposed to be a neat gamer.
And her name was going to be Joystick with an eye.
I know, I don't know why, but...
What about a lollipop with a rat queen?
Wait a second, what? The blacksmith was half-orc.
So she didn't really have green-green skin.
But she still has muscle.
I don't know, I'm going to submit the ideas to the concept art.
See what it comes up with.
And we'll see.
Stop you! Stop you!
Covering before me or whimpering.
Pick your poison, whimper or cower.
Hopefully you guys know where we're going, but I'll just take your word.
Let's get to it, to it.
Let's get this party started.
Let's get them 40's popping.
Let's break their poison, miss them.
Oh, they can't handle our damage.
When we start swinging,
our swords do all the thinking.
These enemies like to be with me.
I suck on their...
Their...
Their souls.
We buy crab sticks,
and we pay no rent.
The world's gone on fire.
The air-trees wait.
I can't do it anymore, it's too hard.
I'm trying to swing into it, but it's hard.
No, MC Stoney in the house.
Cotton bum used to look so chubby in her design.
What was she supposed to see?
So she was always going to be a bunny rabbit.
And we...
We knew we wanted our body type that was a considered alternative.
Because every agency, you look, everyone's a stick.
So we were like, right, we're going to have at least one design that ain't a stick.
Like the default stick type thing.
Which we did get.
And if you didn't know, I see an Emmy.
Emmy's Patan.
But she's actually quite flat in the hips as well.
That's on purpose.
Whereas AC, I mean, she's all hips.
Like we wanted variant body type.
Whoa!
Hold on.
We got some spanking to do.
We got some...
Hello?
Has he targeted me? I don't know, can I spank him?
No, I don't know.
Hold on.
Are you aiming for the refling under the map right now?
Where the heck is he?
Whoa, yeah, where's the Tabarina guy?
I'm helping, I'm helping.
I'm doing nothing, I'm doing nothing.
But I'm helping.
Where is he?
I don't know where the main boss is.
Literally not even in the fight because I don't know where the boss is.
As if he pulled me.
Oh, that's one of these.
Oh, I did just buy that.
Oh, yeah!
Jeez, I'm not dealing with him.
Oh, there he is, there he is, I found him.
What do you mean it's not this big glowing man?
Oh, that was freaking heal.
Don't you blow that horn!
Wait, it's done.
Whoa, where did you guys come from?
Oh, we got a death root, I can feed it to the dog.
I guess we'll just keep going because these guys just keep going.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't know where to go.
Was it that thing back there?
I'm pretty sure I saw it, hold on.
Hold on, let me get on, let me get on Mio's.
Let me get on Mio's.
Ooh, something's making noise.
This guy.
Show me the way.
A pixie would be cool.
The collabs, she's like literally just a tiny thing in the corner
that would actually put comical.
Up the hill?
Up the hill in between north and west, okay.
A pixie?
I can't say I've ever seen a pop lamio.
Ah, he's going to put, maybe.
And she'd have a wee, tiny tail.
Honestly, that'd be pretty cute.
I'm sorry, that'd be adorable.
Wait.
Oh, there's a great sight.
Hello.
Oh, okay, okay.
What was it like?
Oh, well, we're going to keep on, keep on moving up.
Is this it?
Okay, this looks like I've ever seen one.
Right, I think I've got some suggestions to work on.
Eh, doing a little cringey prompt thing.
Wait, I don't need to do that.
Nullified.
Okay, I'm in wide-harm cackles.
Is that where I'm supposed to be?
I hope I'm supposed to be.
A salamander girl?
You a salamander?
A salamander?
A big Sally?
Call her Sally the salamander.
Everyone will remember her name real easy.
In kind.
A cyclope for all?
No, absolutely not.
Eh, real one of each of us have two fucking eyeballs.
That's literally it.
It is very, like, if you do not just straight up have a face,
it, like, you know, you use some alternative type stuff.
Eh, but Mercy has two eyes.
Shut the fuck up, Mercy has two eyes.
Stop arguing with me.
Where you got, what are you...
Wait, I'm in the wrong place?
Oopsies, I'm in the wrong place, sorry.
Okay, let's try that again.
I'm in the wrong place.
I'm being sent away.
I'm being excreted from these purses.
I'm in the wrong place.
No, let's go up right here.
I feel like I'm on my way.
It's all the way to the left, I guess?
Sorry, I may be, uh, being a bit Papiga as I usually am.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think I've gone the complete wrong way.
I've gone the complete wrong way or have I missed on this?
I'm being reassigned.
Sorry, I think I need to go back if there's nothing here.
Oh, I think I've gone the wrong way.
Are you squiddling me right now?
You are just like my GF.
She hides in the back while I do all the work.
Then says, we did it after I'm done defeating the boss.
Myself, hand over mouth, hand over mouth, hand over mouth.
Hand over mouth.
What, you just let my girlfriend, she hides in the back while I do all the work.
Oh, right, okay, I get it now.
Look, princess carrying through games is universal experience, okay?
Thank you for the five kill more, combine.
I get it now, I get it now, but it's fucking true though.
Sorry, let me reread the location.
Located, uh, in milk game more.
Wait, did I not get a grace site?
Did I not get a grace site?
Is this the one?
Fuck it, we're going in deep.
I'm going horseback, baby.
Yeah, this is milk.
So then we're going to keep going north and see what happens.
There must be a shack ahead.
Stinky poopies.
Ow!
Oh, I'm so sorry, Viman.
Sorry, Torren, I'm a terrible right.
I actually don't have my license.
I'm sorry, I just ride a bike usually.
I'm not used to this.
Ah!
See, is there only one?
Yeah, okay.
Whoa, I hear something.
What is it?
A bug!
What's up ahead?
I don't recall.
I see enemies, I see a lot of enemies.
I see enemies.
Save point.
Castello.
Is that you?
Can you please hurry?
The void people are there?
Oh my God.
Oh, there's another one.
Get away.
Get away, you bum.
Are we?
Are we with you?
Oh my God, I can't see.
I can't see none.
I actually can't see none.
I'm sitting down.
It's fine.
Is it this one?
It's not this one.
Johnny, you said the first thing you said you had to issue with your marshmallow.
Has it been fixed?
Nah.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, wrong one.
I meant to put Mully on so I can actually see and get out of this cave.
Nah.
See you.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Right.
If you need to tell me anything that's important, question mark.
Then fucking let me know via...
I shouldn't...
I shouldn't swear.
I mean, I can be swear, but...
Okay, now they drove from the sky.
That cannot feel good.
I regret to inform you that it does not feel good to drive from the sky.
Okay.
Volcanic stone.
Hmm, I wonder if we're going to an area that has volcanic activity.
Trillium mystery.
I remember really liking volcanoes when I was younger.
Well, I had to to in a minute, but I didn't have to.
It went away.
It goes to the sun.
Ooh, what are you?
Fireproof dried liver.
Does that mean you can't receive marshmallows?
No, no one has access to their marshmallows right now.
Oh, there's a map here.
I mean, that's not even going to help.
I've still not came across this bloody village yet.
This bloody village.
Hold on.
Let me just put a little more.
Something's gone for me.
He has triple sprain.
Come on.
That's about OP.
I don't have triple sprain.
Oh, the jellyfish will lead me.
The jellyfish are always at a cavern or is that a grief site?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, this can't be.
There's no gravestone here.
Sugar.
Wait, am I going the complete wrong way?
What am I?
Who or what is fighting?
Something's fighting over there.
Just follow the path.
Oh, sorry.
I thought it was one of the things.
Who is fighting who?
Surely you guys are.
Oh, no.
Wait, there's actual fighting.
I'm so used to everything just going for me.
It's incomprehensible that there's actual fighting going on.
It seems like we're on a battlefield.
I'm getting XP for doing nothing.
What were you?
Reefling?
Reefling is coming here?
Oh, no.
This means it's a boss fight.
Are they coming for me?
Okay.
I think they forgot I existed, which is what I like to hear.
Is there a dragon ahead?
Is there any reeflings able to make it to this really random location at this part of the
map that I haven't unlocked yet?
Uh-huh.
And Mt. Gililmower or whatever.
So we can go wallop a dragon.
Do you think I'll lose?
There is a high probability I'll lose.
Very high probability.
Okay.
Do you think we can do it, Reefling?
Just me and you?
No pressure?
Do you think you can do it?
Oh well, we'll go back up.
That's a good thing.
We'll go back up.
Okay, we'll go back up.
Let's go.
Is there any no-nos?
Insects, mutants, ogres?
So anything that would give the girl a debuff?
I don't want to hear it.
Like, you have to remember that there, like, you can't give someone a...
Stop your whimpering!
We're going to defeat the dragon.
Can we stand in the lake fire?
Or is this dragon going to be, like, in the ear of Wolverine
and just, like, annihilate us all in one go?
Oh, speaking of the dragon.
Uh, oops.
Hold on.
Uh, that's not good.
It's not actually supposed to put your health down.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Okay, I think the lag is, like, terrible right now.
Well, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
I'm getting rolled.
I'm rolling out of the way.
I don't know how.
Please let me heal.
Oh, I got hurt by...
I got spanked by a spot.
And maybe you should have put a fire-resistant talisman on,
but that's not on me.
Wait, you can't hurt him?
Or am I just getting really bad taimans?
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
Um...
Dragonheart.
More like this dragon farted and boosted.
Dun dun dun.
A debuff.
Wait, am I using the word the wrong way around?
A debuff is a negative, a buff is a good.
Can you walk on lava?
Whoa, whoa.
Wait, what?
Can I walk on lava?
Wait, I'm taking damage.
Is torrent taking damage?
Wait, no, this can't be.
Wait, no.
What?
I'm going crazy.
Okay, it is hurting torrent.
Is that a dead end over there?
Sorry, torrent.
I'll keep your vetoes.
He's off.
There you go.
Is this a dead end or not?
No, it's not a dead end.
Nothing?
Yeah, nothing off-putting.
You can't eat someone a model and be like,
oh, sorry, we actually don't know if people will overall
enjoy your model.
But good luck though.
Good luck in your success.
We'll do everything, but then you're on your own.
Smile.
If I hand over a shirt, that's a pillow.
Someone in my group defeated the shard bear.
Go, reeflings, go.
I'm so proud of you.
You're doing it.
That's the bear that AC literally defeated in our
lore video.
Feel old yet?
This is a piece of cheese.
You know those memes that are like, feel old yet?
This is this person you saw this many years ago.
I like hate those memes so much.
So the only version I enjoy is when it's like absolute
nonsense and it's like feel old yet?
This is a piece of day old salmon.
Those are the only ones I can tolerate.
A debuff is a disadvantage.
Can you like, let me be in your hand?
Maybe not in that context, in terms of like,
actual preference of the character.
I've just been in terms of like,
design and stuff, debuff.
But not how the, what?
No, I've unlocked these guys.
Oh, we made it to hermit village.
Okay, now what?
Now what?
Oh, I don't like those guys at all.
I can't stand them.
Am I in trouble?
Oh my, oh my.
Oh my!
I'm actually going to perish.
I'm getting freaking annihilated.
Sit down.
Touch it, touch it, touch it.
Oh my god it's charging up.
It's actually charging up to go for me.
Just charging up to go for me.
are you okay oh there's more enemies than I need to go across this or I need to call
in a weeping calling in a weeping calling in reinforcements because I want to investigate
that chair but there's an enemy right there I grew in the entire area and literally I like
a regen one you thought about what guys would be attracted to chat do we tell the girls were
made with my interests oh you knew oh you're alive the hand moves home it as
you know yeah that's kind of the thing everyone kind of had a bit of something I was interested
in and me broken and AC was a feral scars which are quite late and I kind of like the
idea of like you have to tame her but then eventually like it's you know she all good
to go my god we've been going for it jeez you know some help
whoa hold on a minute okay no poison majors stop it
whoa yeah a memory stone for them does anyone know where we're going
now oh it's too good to be true and it's too good to be true and right hold on what the
instructions on the south west side of hermit village south west is like here so I've gone
too far it's in one of the houses in the village can I spawn you guys back in at the spawnfire
to you know hold my hand across me no you're okay yeah okay I work I work I work I just
work it just works I'll get a vtuber is called Howard I'm kidding I don't understand how being
an insect or spider is a debuff and right I'm not gonna sound like an ass hat and I mean
absolutely nothing when I say this but name one bug vtuber right now I'm gonna be honest
and say I can't and I don't mean that in a nasty way but right so and all those names
you've all just typed I recognize one yeah it's not like an endless list it's like you guys have
repeated two of the same names over and over like I don't mean it in a bad way and I'm sure it's
probably gonna frustrate people but you have to like is there no other reason that can come in
oh and like I'm sure it's gonna frustrate people like oh my god you didn't make the exact
design I wanted but like please be realistic like one like if I'm gonna get shit for like telling
like the behind the scenes stuff like I'm happy to shut up and just like quiet but like the fun
part is that we can do these discussions and I can be like look I'm gonna be honest bug vtuber
is a debuff it might be hard to imagine it is not like a good thing like the reason why you know
and the Visho Joe bug is because well fucking Visho Joe and also they came with like an absolutely
insane amount behind like if you mean I mean like actual insect and that's the only insect I
think someone was saying a moth or whatever but that's not like if you're talking like insect
like centipede arachnid type star oh it was like actually in the village
late when you consume content well so all of you can actually do this right now when you
consume content you can literally look into the success factors of what Lake has made someone
and like as you start to analize and kind of get past the point of you cute girl that's why she's
successful it's like no motherfucker look harder and it's like there's one bug girl that you guys can
all name off the top of your head hasn't said before I don't but like if you want to talk about
it I'm happy to talk about it but like wait this is southwest that's southeast of the village
look we got it we got it hold on let's do a little cheeky x next up on the clock we have
let's get to it which is located in the scene to heroes grave and artists hotel
I think it's time we flings for you to it's we will time baby also depends a lot on what
the kind of feel is a bug whichever could be killed but could she be yeah an intake girl is
just not gonna have the same pro drill when compared to a different type of thing yeah now
you can be like you're caught officially fucking relax I'm the like uh well a rampart for this one
rampart half
if you want to start a bug feature agency didn't let me stop you go off and make one yourself
honestly I was my favorite my my favorite response to that or whatever was lit oh wait
should I just rape the horse I don't know where I'm going sorry I don't know where I'm going you
guys are gonna have to guide me I was like oh I'm not hiring male sexist I was like what
stopped me from not your male branch hmm is it hmm the funds to do it hmm fucking curious
me fucking curious like oh fuck off honestly
oh when are you gonna open up a male branch you mean at the feature agency that specifically
has like people behind the scenes that know how they have made content as checks when are we gonna
open up the male branch bro the only thing I'll open it up is your fucking arsehole bend over
like shut up anyway this is me fighting demons again um okay okay right I think we're doing it
I think we're doing it
male's interacting with velour less likely than you think much less in fact it's actually next
to impossible oh don't get struck by lightning oh wait you can't be hurt by can you be hurt by
environmental factors if you're the bad day I'm honing in look I can't lose my guiding light
I'm honing in male beggars and shambles male mentioned on the stream the male branch
unfortunately fell off the tree oh that's so good like I was entertaining like a spin-off thing but
I have actually no fucking desire like every time you open up like Twitter there'll be like a thing
and be like
I'm like bro can you whoa whoa whoa you're fast and not the good way oh sorry I shouldn't have done
that hold on let me recover some stamina please let me recover some stamina I don't really want to
just be taking wax man I love being too handed oh my god I love breaking poise hold on let me
recover some stamina bro
hold on this is the most specific fight I think I've ever done okay there we go
an enemy fell oh no wait you disappeared instantly what the heck
you didn't even give us a chance to breathe name what technically you're currently interacting
with mills and chart all right get it out then do what I want get it out
hold it right now
she hates us right where's that heck are we oh we're going down
we're yelling Simba oh look at you guys already waiting to get me
okay right one two installed a bit two and then tweet
time to become a girl oh I hear something
oh
everybody let's get two two let's get this party right what was in here
other than a foul beast what were you feasting on a crimson sea
what does that do raise base hp yeah we kind of look good oh god what did I have on stamina
that looks right travel we took your stamina 17 minutes left oh wait what we got we've got
two more right we're well we can finish the base coconut and it feels weird I like not even getting
started like what do you mean we're already finished we and ironically just got here
other magic okay careful
secret door secret door
oh well you just go for it
why is it going gold I don't like that why are you glowing I'm sorry I never told you
why is it going you're getting nervous a torch bear I'm strange
eight hours and 17 minutes left you mean no I'm gonna try and lie down and actually get
sleep literally four hours is oh one long way my apologies
can't just ask something nice going can't just happen
the enemies are invulnerable in the shadow oh yeah please drag them into it
oh wow you're right
beat them up
you're welcome
see you and you'd be magic
I don't really know what you do I don't know how deep people get into crafting in this game
get rested get rested get rested let's live I'm gonna I pray I just get a big sleep
or a big nap I'll take anything at this point I honestly will I'll take anything
I'm um I'm no well oh I'm also fucking completely missing I'm gonna get some limelight
hiding behind here be honest are you hiding
yeah
you listen to ASMR to sleep now I see people playing video games
I'm currently watching Civ 6 gameplay and I just kind of wrap my head around all this and stuff
I'm currently watching someone play Scotland and it was the funniest thing ever and because it was like
he had like a really bad start and I have no idea what's going on
and he's like oh this is bad this is bad this is bad oh shit sorry oh my god
whoa where's the spot
you just tell me there's a horse just being cheap sounds so much
we're keeping each other safe that's what we're doing
oh
if I managed to fall asleep uh actually hold on I should probably ask you guys this
uh
hold on hold on hold on oh that could have gone in a rush just
um I can either go straight to sleep or I can upload that audio because I do
but if I get some sleep I can also edit the thank you videos and just get a lot of like
behind the scenes stuff done um
yeah wait we can't hurt him
right just a second for that hold on right let's get over here let's get over here
we're gonna be in trouble
oh
uh definitely go down the guy might be coming down with us please don't nothing to be alarmed
about nothing at all oh shit that was the one oh shit this is terrible news oh
oh
are we not doing the boss why wait can I really not hurt him oh for folks sake
right hold on let me let me let me let me get over here sorry let me get over here
okay okay okay we need to get him all the way back here just to wallop him hold on hydrogen
hydrogen
okay and let me guess he doesn't follow now he just gives up
is he fighting who's he locked on to not one of you
I look like he was locked on to one of the spear things the shadow man
uh
hey hey like literally meals before the way yeah that's what
rubbish don't do that again
I'm not even hungry I actually don't normally eat until like a couple of hours into the stream
isn't it not this one this thing
isn't it up there I seem to recall having to uh jump up
oh no you guys are right I mean you guys are always right I don't know why I even pretend
I don't know what I'm doing you guys are all literally always right
I'm gonna be fellow beast
I'm just checking there wasn't like a cheeky eye
what we got some sort of leech
skinny melinky long legs okay we both messed up I'm embarrassing for the both of us honestly
okay
no has high poise doesn't get staggered like that what is he doing magic I don't know what he's doing
okay okay we're good we're good it's fine we got the ancient dragon knight crystal
oh I like that jeez that moon magic is kind of crazy it's just a ward is this a ward that
keeps you stronger it must be that keeps you stronger in magic
I just see you see well we grab these items even though I don't even craft anything
okay the last one in base game needs might take a while
oh no let's get wait there's a teleport out of this one wait am I going through
oh normally there's a little teleport thing my beloved one of the branches just below the tree
canopy grace at the start of mackayla's high tree wait I'm not even been to that location yet
oh no that's like we can get it just yet can we get the whimpering one
we can get the lamentors well wait where's it is there an exit am I going crazy is there really
not an exit like little wait spindly uh really after what I can't believe it
the whimpering one is dlc I think I unlocked the area nearby if anyone's dlc section
um
did I come I came this way
there is something up here but I can't remember
I don't know if it's just maybe an item
up here oh
oh my god I actually have to be brave and do this without my replays man I hate it
whoa uh I didn't do much damage I'm okay
right we get it oh my god I hate when they do that
oh and there's another one just do it just to top off
stop it what is this area
right seems to be some sort of reward under this
hold on a minute there's an enemy under here wash off the runny whoa
it wouldn't let me attack there because of that notification okay I got talisman that was decent
talisman are like kind of worth the key is this still the dlc no we went back to get the prattling
a weak coconut because I am very not well and I just need to do a short spoon today and
however I seem I go up in order to get out oh I got ashes ashes of war
I'm not gonna get lost hold on wait I've been in this place before I have no recollection of this
place but I've been in this place before as long as I'm going up I think I'm going the right way
okay yeah because we killed those guys that is really early okay I think we're good
just teleport out oh you can teleport out okay okay okay okay okay right we're going dlc
and it's the some location in the dlc I think um
you should go to chadows hero grave oh god I've not learned the names of these places
chadows hero grave sure wait
wait why is it doing it like that
this is a dragon area oh chadows hidden grave
if you push too much we'll have to contact your cats to tie you up and put you in bed
honestly I don't know if any reeflings are at this section though well I heard I heard a noise
it sounds like one of them is it's about enemy reeflings got enemies got a lead enemy oh I saw
that one don't worry I'll get you back in we're just don't rely on reeflings for two minutes
challenge impossible damn straight it's impossible I don't want to be on what one I'm too scared
this game is it's literally a horror game when I can't spawn you guys in I can't remember what
section yesterday I couldn't have you guys in I was dying a day kidney handle it
kidney handle it at least I have a reefling to help me through the scary bit
no I don't rub it in my face we're trying to get it does that not work
wait hold on hold on I can talk a little bit now
let's get to it ah let me mark off the list and then we're gonna get the morning coconut
instead beautiful right and then last but not last morning coconut that's literally what we're
calling it oh no it's not it's whimpering we're getting the whimpering one do you get
spooked easily in horror games I can hardly play them I don't actually play them like in my in my
in my free time I don't play horror games let's get to it uh is there no other reefling that can
join are we too high are we too high in the dlc yeah I think we are okay um okay gating light we
have a torch actually I think that playing you would have been saying because the bosses would
have a normal health but I can get to your point scary monsters yeah I don't like when it's all on
me like it's why I really enjoy Assassin's Creed brotherhood because like even if you're bad you
have things to rely on you to help you like get through the game like you can use the crossbow
for stealth and all that and you can call on your assassin recruits like it's a nice oh my god there
might not be a spider on my foot I don't know why I feel sorry I literally felt something on my foot
and I was like oh spider uh no it's actually just a reason hitting hitting I'm having a stroke
literally my life that's it right now
I mean Elder Ring does have spirit ashes and but is it the same
I got jumped in you're not sitting on your feet no I'm sitting with my legs pressed against the
desk so my feet are on the chair right now I can't sit on them at the moment uh due to the
minor loss of a body part um there will not be any feet sitting on for quite a while
but I can sit with them up at least which I'm happy about
there's no reefing spirit ashes just not the same I'm not gonna make it
sheebie is going live in t-minus one minute uh I will be redirecting into her once we pick up this
frattle and coconut and then I'm gonna tuck myself nice and tidy into my bed oh the worms are angry
there's blue jean
oh no wouldn't want to be wrapped up in their tentacles oh no
oh
to recovery for I do not think so I think uh I think we're
the yeah I think it's um I think it's ogre it's truly ogre it's the it's the end of a oh it's in here
you stop that whimpering I'll whimper back in a minute once I get this coconut
hold on let me put my little light on let me make sure I'm illuminated the worms are really
confirmed my little tentacles why you're all in here hello uh is there anyone here that
haven't had a chance to join in yeah I wish you needed to get in made you feel like you've not
had a chance oh oops sorry how can we kiss you to better we can't see it you want to kiss my
mangled gory toes sure okay I think you too haven't had a chance to be in yet
uh but oh my god this is so weird this is like the last thing we're doing and then
we're literally going africate oh no wait who do you think coming
is it my connection or is it your connection be honest
it's probably the servers and overlord no I got inappropriate activity
it's so weird
I'll get enemy reflux gaden like uh but yeah I'm like
the good thing is I think I'll be able to go to the shops and buy myself like actual food
because I've been having to rely on like takeaway for quite a while now and I think
that's also not helping with my four-day loaf of bread because that tiny little thing I produced
yesterday I'm probably on day five in all honesty um takeaway is good but I am not looking after
myself because I'm like having so much fun streaming like I said like as soon as I click go live I
don't feel stressed I feel excited I want to share the plans I want to share like the things
like Azura has just hit over 5 000 subscribers ac is like just shy of it if you're not subscribed
to ac snowfalls her link is in my description and then literally in under a month all members
of VLR have hit 5 000 subscribers which is just insane for a new like we um
I'm
carful like that is it car is it carful is it really a corporation if they can do what they
want for the most of the part for the most part wait I can't see anyone else
I'm gonna try and I know I want to be selfish but I'm trying to beat this area you want me to come
yeah everyone's been monetized everyone's about to hit at least 5k there's like ASMR
collabs on the way like I'm just so excited for all these wee things to finally come out
um I got to see the video game animation um there I'm gonna say it might still come out in July
near the end I'm not sure how fast this animators working but um like the games come in the games
free access and all that jazz so don't worry are you working him with that
the corporation ran by an anti-corporal it's enemy levels of funny honestly though
stop whimpering great come on let's go let's go let's go time to have 6k hours oh no the the maximum
if you want to unlock all the wee thingies and they're very small like if you're
you know if not everyone is your flavor and in the agency then you're probably only gonna play
through it once um what's going on here not that way I guess um but if everyone is your flavor
or you just have a genuine curiosity then um you can probably you're the full unlock play
time would be an hour um but it would be mildly repetitive other than the new voice playing
here and there to take a different order of things um it's not it's not anything major
so this is a warrior door
and then I can spoil all the behind the scenes of what it's like to make a video game
are you ready
oh
wait why does it call it that oh he looks so sad he's blue
amidst a blissful lamentation what's lamentation
what's lamentation I will be putting 100 hours into it you can it would be too repetitive
literally if you unlock everything then there's nothing else there's no like hidden secrets before
anyone's like oh my god strongy such an elite gamer that she would put in hidden secrets if you do
this in this order no there's none of that do not torture yourself thinking there's any hidden
secrets everything is there oh sorry replaying
uh we got a key okay
blissful lamentation is just a funny word for why would they put that in the game
a way to hear strongy every day and some scenes gonna play an extra two no it's not that
like please like remember first of her attempt at like commission oh my god reflin are you okay
that looks like that hurt I'm not gonna lie um
um
oh wait they don't even have a name
who's screaming today
um is it gonna be on steam no it can't be
stop screaming okay I think I know why the coconut of screaming is in here
what are you
they're like straight up doing everything for me it's gonna be on it too
ah no no no no no no no
do you have a heal you okay okay you guys got healed okay you got heals
oh what happened what did you do
oh my god you got jumped no are we to go down oh can you cast magic in here
oh I have to admit the Billy it cast magic from afar yeah this is exactly why
oh reflin I don't need to
uh a completion bar no but it will be very apparent like what you can unlock and what
replaying would do so you're not wasting your time if you play it and you're like not sorry
um you will not be wasting your time I'm not gonna waste your time yeah I was gonna say that
fake is anything oh it's locked
like you will not waste your time in the game you'll either like it you won't like it you'll
instantly after the first instance of it which is not even five minutes you will completely
understand what the game is and if you want to continue you most certainly can to unlock scenes
and if you don't want to continue you don't have to it's completely optional it's a and it's a free
game so it's not like oh I've wasted my time and if anyone memes and be like oh but sorry I wasted
my money but if anyone means it's like oh oh they're doing a song up there and we make sure right
who's you yeah I don't trust none of this
we baby Alexander's everywhere
wow oh sorry sorry there's a pot behind you replaying I'm so sorry it'll pay to you
okay I'm getting rolled by a pot I'm I'm getting ruled by a baby pot as well oh my god you're going for my ankles
see this is whoa we're getting jumped like unironically getting jumped hold on
no no no no no no not like this not like this not like this not like this not like this hold on
oh fuck off okay okay let me heal I said let me heal
okay okay okay major melee we can do it major melee people
you do it oh I didn't like that sorry I messed up I couldn't have done it any harder than I thought
I love when you lose your train of thought because I'm so dumb
another key is that for that gate that we just passed wow what's up here
is it the way to go yay I found the way to go
ah okay sorry broken die I was gonna say
I almost roll down there absolutely nothing it's an abyss down there the complete abyss
okay this is the other beefling this oh wait hold on we're going too fast oh there you are okay okay
it's a jar bang and then this looks okay okay
we're getting jumped by something in this room I don't trust it maybe not maybe not
lamenting visage lament in face
oh my visage promise you
fuck I'm so terrible at slamming sentences together in french it's terrible
all the all the grammar is wrong all the fucking gendering the loo and the lies are wrong
everything's wrong whoa what the oh
oh
mealy mealy mealy
and i'm magic oh
oh
oh uh huh huh oh there's like angst ahead
this
okay oh something's showing us you don't have any more healing me tree
it was jarring one mate see
oh thank you thank you oh you're too kind too much too kind
oh no oh no this can't be uh i'm not sure we're gonna make this
that's quite the journey just to get back to the boss i don't know because are we statue of
dibella here no okay we're getting all healed up that was a good one yeah i thought of it myself
yep
where can i find a place to perish why are you trying to perish right are we ready
i have no idea what the boss is oh it's a person lamenter okay what do you do nothing
um i don't want to jinx it but
i think uh
why are you mourning where is it
whoa
uh what
whoa whoa
okay at least i one shot him i'm gonna do that
uh oh you found it
whoa
no no no don't do it again
shit right so he just keeps giving us hoards basically wait what's that on my around my face
is it time out or are we in trouble i don't know if we're in trouble
i don't know if we're in trouble
whoa you're awfully aggressive for uh a wannabe
i think it's him sitting a fucking aggressive he is no no it's it's not him wait am i being
picked up no i'm not i was gonna see you're acting
acting awfully aggressive for something that's not like to be hidden
hold on again
uh
i don't know what these random horns in front of me are though
oh well found him consider him bloody aggressive
hold on are you
no
oh you found him
okay we're doing it we're doing it wow
ah
whoa talk about a fucking delay
whoa whoa whoa whoa you found him you did it oh you did it
whoa okay oh my goodness what do you need for
oh no is that you're beautiful no we did it we did it
because they and my mummies better than perishing
mission complete we got our prattling oh my god it's so weird being like well that's
on the stream i fucking didn't even get started right hold on let me add a little x just to
satisfy everyone across the board um right and she's through oh she be oh wait no i can actually
do it um
hold on content live this is oh you're getting the behind the scenes now content live edit
customization redirect like videos from other channels and it's true save there we go we're
you're great at prattling and yeah yes go get some rest i absolutely am um for those of you who
are patreon members an armpit is going to be going up um either after my nap or before
we don't know yet hi stony hi chat oh no we're we're about to go you've come right at the end
i'm having a very short stream today unfortunately i need to get some rest because i've had four
hours of sleep um and i'm not very healthy at the moment so uh i'm gonna rest i'm gonna go to
the shops and get myself some has stony started whimpering yet oh you bet i have hold on you
bet i've started whimpering not that one uh this one
and the only one we're missing is my beloved but that's because i actually haven't activated that
part of the thing um uh yeah she finally got it you're going to actually take care of yourself
i know it's a christmas miracle please get some proper sleep drinks and fancy yes i'm going to
i'm gonna make my oh i say i'm gonna make myself a sunday roast that's not true
i'm buying up i'm already made in season chicken and then i'm gonna just roast some vegetables and
i hope that like completely flushes out my system i'm also gonna get a lot of fruit drinks as well
i think because i i would recommend watching a video on how to get to the hallig tree we can't
co-op there very well no the freaking the wind place i can hardly call you guys in at the wind
place but yeah a frozen roast dinner no no no not microwave like i like cut the vegetables off
and then you add like oil and then you add like all the seasoning and stuff i know how like i can
do that i can make that so i'm gonna do it i also do need to get some sunlight i ain't been outside
in a very long time i'll go for a walk yeah i should go for a walk but yes i am going to redirect
into my lovely gen mate uh lovely jubilee gen mate she be caught in boom who is doing art i believe
i don't know what she's creating or what this crazy woman is up to but we'll find out very shortly
thank you so so much for being so understanding about having a shorter stream i assure you it
feels weird for me as weird as it is for you but thank you for everyone sorry if you just
heard my stomach there um thank you everyone for your suggestions that's fantastic i'm gonna
feed that back to the development team um there and you may or may not have a mild insight on
what's coming up uh velour headquarters but yes thank you so so much wait your feature
but you can't you can't touch grass um but yes thank you so so much for being so patient for me
um and hopefully tomorrow i can't even remember well tomorrow with uh tomorrow is a collab with
yumi plus um so i'm doing asmr then we're doing a quick member stream and i'm going to test if
you guys like the behind the scenes on script writing or if you don't like the behind the scenes
if it's liked i'm happy to do more if it's not liked i will think of something else
okay my little reeflings and then i have a fantastic two-hour collab with the velour girls as well
as the yumi plus girls it's a 4v4 but we can't actually verse each other because we don't know
who's going to get in trouble or not um so we'll find out tomorrow what happens we're not going
to keep a scoreboard it's just some girls hanging out in your house um but yes please do how a
lovely evening i'm going to bed right now i'm going to lie down a bit i will be uploading armpit
very shortly please allow me to have a quick little nap and it's all i beg please i plead with you let
me nap um thank you so so much i will see you tomorrow for some shenanigans as we always get
up to because when we shenan once we shenanigan in this reefling house thank you so so much guys
please enjoy she be uh as much uh she'll enjoy you yes okay right i'll see you later alligators
okay bye reeflings we'll see you tomorrow thank you for being so understanding about my situation
bye